welcome to thick boy fighters let's dive
in youtube star boxer and now
professional wrestler logan paul
appeared at wwe summerslam over the
weekend going viral for his electric
frog splash body slam despite having
success in the wwe paul doesn't plan on
giving up his love for boxing appearing
on the pat mcafee show sweaty and in
boxing attire paul shared that there are
plans for him to return to the ring for
the first time since facing floyd
mayweather in june of 2021 that's why i
was late i was sparring i'm a boxer
again we're getting back in the ring
we're going to go from professional
sport to professional sport i want to
get a fight in december when asked about
any potential opponents paul deferred to
keep that information to himself i have
some people in mind but i can't say you
know you only get one first impression
that's part of my ability to make
moments i like making first impressions
big so i want to wait until we're ready
the other paul brother jake has been
taking heat over the cancellation of his
boxing bout against haseem rahman jr the
bout scheduled to take place on august
6th in madison square garden was
officially cancelled due to weight
issues from rahman junior but fans and
media alike have theorized that the real
reason the bout was cancelled was due to
low ticket sales comedian actor and
sports personality michael rappaport
took to social media to blast paul over
the cancelled fight and accused him of
covering up the real reason
fake pull
fake pull don't front stop the lying and
the bull crapping your fight that was
supposed to go down in the world's most
famous arena madison square garden
didn't get cancelled because of some
weight thing
to the fake fighter that you were gonna
you were gonna fight at madison madison
square garden it got canceled because no
one bought tickets
okay because the ghosts of madison
square garden in the same arena where
i'll leave fort frazier where jake
lamotta fought sugar ray robins were
hulk hogan
fought andre the giant madison square
garden they did not want to see you in
there no one bought tickets to that fake
fight fake pole you're not a fighter you
want to be a real fighter fight a real
fighter okay
take a real drug test
okay
the rules the con the bull jive
is over
fake call
but remember michael if you come at jake
paul he'll come back harder and will be
waiting conor mcgregor will be taking
his talents from the octagon onto the
silver screen for the first time a
report from deadlines stated that
mcgregor has a role in prime video's
upcoming remake of roadhouse according
to the report the film will star jake
gyllenhaal as a former ufc fighter
turned bouncer in the florida keys
mcgregor's role in the film is still
unclear however the report does claim
that he will not be appearing as himself
mcgregor's spokesperson karen kessler
confirmed the deadline report in a
statement given to mma junkie conor
mcgregor is very excited to expand his
storied career to hollywood and join
with jake gyllenhaal in this reimagining
of roadhouse a beloved classic while
fighting remains his top focus this is
the beginning of another successful
venture in the mcgregor empire he is
eager to get started filming on the most
recent episode of the weighing in
podcast host josh thompson and big john
mccarthy spoke about dan hooker's recent
twitter call out of tony ferguson both
men expressed interest in seeing such a
fight despite the string of recent
losses by the fighters uh dan hooker is
calling it tony ferguson what do you
guys think about that face i like that
i like that fight i think that's a good
fight for both i think that's a good
fight for tony i think it's a good fight
for dan hooker i like the call out
i'll smash your face in not too sure
about that
i think it would be a really good fight
i think that's a great match up in the
yes tony got knocked out in his last
fight and it wasn't you know knocked out
in a big way but he was actually doing
well
at moments in that fight and i think
that he matches up very well with dan
hooker i think
he could submit dan hooker if he ends up
in the top position on the ground or
anything like that he's got the ability
to hurt dan hooker we've seen dan hooker
hurt dan hooker has the ability to get
in and and light tony epidemics i think
it's a great matchup i would love to see
it
sign me up man sign me up i think both
of them i think is a fantastic fight
both are tall long and lanky i think
it's a great fight i agree with you 100
on how this thing gets done if tony
ferguson gets to fight to the grounds a
good chance he can sub him
darcy's anacondas uh ankle locks all
those things arm bars triangles
i mean he's got all the tools on the
ground to get this thing done kimura's
at all but i would look at this fight
and dan hooker on the feet possesses the
power and possessed all those skills to
knock him out as well given tony's
last fight now like you said
it happens man you fight long enough
these things [ __ ] happen and when you
fight the best guys like he's been
fighting for the longest time
it's gonna happen look at the list of
guys that tony has fought in his last
whoa whoa whoa whoa let's not bring up
the list okay let's move on anyways
wow
wow my my boy trying to throw me under
over here look at the little no no no
there's josh
right there not talking about his wins i
was talking about his like he's got a
string of losses but let's take a look
at those who he's facing justin gaichy
right
freaking charles oliveira
you know benil and then michael chandler
look he's
he can't get any easy fights
ufc heavyweight champion francis naganu
shared a video to social media meeting
boxing heavyweight deontay wilder
blessing blessings good to meet you
good training
wilder who hasn't fought since his
second loss to tyson fury in october
2021 seems to be getting back in the
boxing shape the naganu video was the
second post on social media alluding to
his return with badu jack tweeting good
to see at bronze bomber back in the gym
today according to
boxingnews24.com the boxing community is
speculating that wilder is training to
take on the winner of andy ruiz jr and
luis ortiz looking for more original mma
content check out the rest of thick boy
youtube exclusive interviews opinion and
fight analysis is available weekly on
the shob show food truck diaries and
fight night flashbacks subscribe so you
don't miss any of the action
you